I've never really shied away from topics
that have the high probability of having
videos be demonetized because some of
these topics are the ones I find most
interesting in the building of immersion
by comparing video game commentary to
real life
this video definitely won't be for
everyone but for geeks like myself who
like to dive that little bit deeper I
think this is one topic that I'm sure
we've all been thinking about
[Music]
the division and the division 2 are
games that depict a dystopian future of
New York and Washington DC in which the
world has been ravaged by a deadly virus
causing widespread chaos and collapse of
societal norms they have a narrative
that delves into deep social and
political commentary the fact This World
Isn't So dissimilar to our own prompts
us to reflect on the real-life
implications of the events depicted in
the game this video will explore and
compare the themes of social and
political commentary in the division
story to real life
real life issues such as Government
response inequality corruption abuse of
power Collective action and extremist
groups
in a way the games showcase the
disastrous consequences of such issues
and highlight the importance of taking
action to prevent them
the games also present a vision of what
could happen if we fail to address these
issues in this world societies crumbled
in the most basic necessities of life
such as food water and shelter are
scarce commodities
violence is rampant and the rule of law
has broken down
the games remind us that if we fail to
address the underlying causes of social
and political issues we could actually
be headed for a similar fate sometime in
the near-distant future
a set in a world in which the government
and Society have failed to adequately
respond to a crisis leading to the
breakdown of social order
this is a theme that resonates with many
real-life events that have occurred over
the last couple of decades in all
instances we have seen how governments
have been overwhelmed by the magnitude
of the crisis leading to the breakdown
of social order and the emergence of a
state of chaos albeit to a much lesser
scale than the games have portrayed but
the devastation of these events have
also been on a law scale
by depicting a world in which the
government in society have failed to
respond to the crisis the division has
highlighted the importance of effective
governance and the need for society to
come together in the face of adversity
the division explores the theme of class
and inequality in both games the
division between the heaves and the
have-nots is evident would the wealthy
living in luxury while the poor struggle
to survive
we saw this in the DC dark zones with
the wealthier side of the city pushed
for the supposed cure ahead of the other
regions
now this cure was actually dc62 and we
know how this worked out but that's
beside the point they were given
preferential treatment because of the
power and money this area had
this theme is all too relevant to now
world where income inequality is on the
rise and the wealth Gap is widening this
only forces us to question the fairness
and sustainability of a system that
benefits only a privileged few while
leaving the rest of the population to
fend for themselves
the wealthy and Powerful are often given
preferential treatment leaving the most
vulnerable members of society to suffer
the most
in both games we see how this unequal
treatment results in the creation of
factions and gangs that prey on the weak
and defenseless
the theme of corruption has also
explored in the division the game show
world in which those in power are not
always acting in the best interests of
the people they're supposed to serve
instead they use their position to serve
their own interests leading to a
breakdown of trust between the
government and the people
this theme is reflected in real life
where we have seen numerous examples of
corruption and abuse of power by those
in positions of authority leading to a
loss of trust and government
institutions
in the real world we can see the impact
of government corruption on societies
around the globe for example in many
countries politicians and leaders use
their positions of power to enrich
themselves and their families while
neglecting the needs of the people
this is evident in the fictional world
of the division where corrupt officials
and organizations have allowed the
outbreak of a deadly virus to spiral out
of control resulting in the complete
collapse of society
the theme of government overreach and
abuse of power in the division the
government has shown to be corrupt and
inefficient in its attempts to restore
order a portrayed as heavy-handed and
misguided with the agents being forced
to push back against the oppressive
tactics used by the government
this could be seen as a reflection of
the mistrust many have with their own
governments as well as a commentary on
the dangers of unchecked government
power
the importance of community and power of
collective action is heavily highlighted
especially in The Division II
agents in the community must work
together to overcome challenges and
rebuild Society
the player is part of a group of agents
who work together to rebuild society and
fight back against the various factions
and gangs that have taken over the
streets
the games underscore the importance of
cooperation and collaboration which is
especially relevant in our world with
social isolation and individualism can
lead to the breakdown of social order
and the erosion of societal norms
the emphasis on the power of collective
action is a reminder that social and
political issues can only be solved
through the combined effort of many
people working together
the games offer a hopeful message that
even in the darkest times we can find
Hope and make a difference by coming
together to work for the greater good
[Music]
another real-life issue that the
division tackles is the rise of
extremist groups and the potential for
civil unrest
extremist groups have played a
significant role in the division
reflecting real life concerns about the
rise of extremist ideologies and
movements around the world
the portrayal of groups in both games
raises important questions about the
nature of political extremism and the
factors that contribute to its rise
in particular the games highlight the
dangers of extremism in a world where
social and political structures are
breaking down and people are struggling
to survive
one key theme that emerges is the way in
which extremist groups are able to
exploit people's fears and anxiety to
gain power and influence
in both games the player encounters
characters who have been drawn into
these groups because they believe that
these groups offer protection and
Security in a chaotic world
these groups or factions are shown to be
vying for control of the city and are
often at odds with one another
this can be seen as a reflection of the
growing polarization and tribalism in
modern Politics as well as a commentary
on the dangers of extremism and the
potential for violence
the division shows how these groups can
emerge and gain power in the absence of
strong social and political structures
and how important it is to resist their
influence and defend societal values
in conclusion the division offers a rich
commentary on the state of our world
highlighting many of the social and
political issues we face today
through the depiction of a dystopian
future the game's forces to reflect on
the real-life implications on the events
shown in the game
by exploring themes such as class and
inequality corruption and the importance
of community the games provide a
compelling narrative that not only
provides a great story but also prompts
us to consider the world we live in and
the challenges we Face going forward
it confronts us with the consequences of
inaction and the potential for both good
and bad in humanity
I'll admit this video was pretty deep
but I love this stuff let's call it
another shell thoughts video well maybe
it's just another instance where I'm
trying to open people's eyes through the
power of video games
nah that sounds a little bit too
revolutionist for me I just thought the
comparison was interesting
anyway if you like this sort of Deep
dive into the story and maybe the
unintended meaning behind it let me know
in the comments these are certainly a
favorite for me otherwise thank you very
much for watching and extremist malice
extreme remedia
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you